hi this is fresh to occur in this video
I'm going to explain the math proof of
how you can calculate cube roots in your
head here's how the trick works again
your friend selects a two-digit number
and then cubes that number tells you the
cube and you can instantly figure out
what their original number was so here's
how it works
any two-digit number XY is written as 10
X plus y because the X is in the tens
place when we cube the number if we
expand out the terms we have a thousand
x cubed plus 300 XY squared plus 300 Y x
squared plus y cubed so this Y cubed
will be the only value that's in the
unit's digit so the last digit of the
number we can backtrack from Y cubed to
get the last digit Y and the part where
we ignore the first the last three
digits this is comes from the fact that
we have a thousand X cubed so we want to
look to whatever the number is closest
to x cubed in the thousands place we're
going to have some extra amount beyond X
cubed because we have this 300 XY
squared plus 300 y squared X so we want
to look to the closest one I hope you
liked this video please subscribe to my
channel you can support me on patreon
catch me on my blog minor decisions on
Twitter at pressure locker and you can
get my books listed on my website
you